hi there reject nation of Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we are going to watch a
video from the YouTube channel
girlfriend reviews description is my
name is Shelby we make videos about the
games i watch my boyfriend Matt play I
have never seen this YouTube channel
this is a topper war to your video
requests from man named Pete dawn this
video is called should your boyfriend
play grand theft auto 5 yes if you
wanted to be tempted by sin and hookers
and that might enroll murder it's awful
I think you can actually see some full
frontal nudity in the stripper section
of the game really in Grand Theft Auto 5
all boyfriend should be playing this
unless you want me to cheat on you keep
Sam out of a real way he gets it out of
it yep my boyfriend had always made me
feel like his one true love microwave
till one day moment of weakness he was
tempted
the only time he has ever said I me need
to talk was when he warned me about Red
Dead Redemption to his release date like
it was the last day we'd ever see each
other
my dad made his hop up so much time make
him talk so much like the cowboy and
made him kill so many Bambi's and I
started a YouTube channel where I could
complain about it in the seven months
since I was in dude 32 games and now
consider myself a professional eye
watching someone else play them that's
why when my boyfriend told me he had a
hankering for another roster game I
still died a little inside and died a
little inside with no I said right
this isn't a review grand theft auto 5
this is a review of what it's like to
live with someone who plays grand theft
auto 5 this video was brought to you by
skills girl sure free trial hang out to
the end of the video but good news
everyone loves skill shot more fun to
watch the Red Dead Redemption to journal
unrealistic emotional experience that
makes you feel like you're in an academy
award-winning western movie the GTA is
an unethical experience that makes you
feel like you're in a raspberry
for example I'm already dead my
boyfriend would spend hours tracking and
hunting Cougars
but in GTA he would chase them up a
mountain in a stolen car race if Jaguar
wheels not even in red dead he would use
cinematic mode to activate Auto travel
which meant I was basically just staring
at a pony ride he was devoted to
immersion and treated every moment as if
he were an actual cowboy on the American
frontier he invested entire real-life
days into going in GTA he was also
devoted to the draw every moment as if
he were an actual resident of Los
Angeles California
he invested entire real-life days into
never using his turn signals appearances
underpaying
committing time septum do you crime at
all it's true the point I'm trying to
make is that even if your backseat
gaming GTA 5 is pure comedy and not just
because the plot is a ruthless satire on
contemporary stupidity Oh sticker
underpants off or because the script is
full of low-hanging potty humor oh I saw
his danger the real comedians were the
programmers who made their own satire on
the laws of physics
kick the director took the step back and
said wow this is the most beautiful
lifelike city ever constructed in a
video game we may only be decades away
from simulating a reality
indistinguishable from our own and on
that day
Rockstar will be no less than a god but
for now let's recode everything to be
wildly unreasonable this is food this is
the funniest gameplay I've ever seen I
don't think five minutes can go by in
GTA the whole of the moments the
missions can be incredibly fun
particularly those where you plan and
execute a heist but the missions can
also be incredibly not that great why
would anyone want to tow a car or stack
shipping containers when they can go off
some sweet jumps at LAX almost always
involve driving to the Merkur that
starts the mission and then getting
right back in the car and driving to
where the mission actually takes place
[Music]
when there's a 10% chance all that
driving will be to me it's just easier
to make your own son such as off-roading
it's definitely the most consistently
entertaining backseat gaming experience
at Los Santos is a great place to
introduce a loved one to video games in
the same way that a playground is a
great place to introduce a this has made
a lot of people angry
I've been widely regarded as six billion
dollars the end but who needs fancy
college classes when their skill share
skill sure is an online learning
community for creative business with a
premium membership you'll get unlimited
access so you can join all the classes
and communities that are perfect for you
whether you want a duel you're curious
skill share we also have skill share is
also super affordable a subscription
will cost you less than $10 a month join
more than 7 million creators learning
with skill share by clicking the link in
the description for your free two-month
trial of premium all right guys thanks
for watching I had so much fun playing
GTA with my boyfriend and all of you who
hang out with us on Twitch be sure to
follow us there if you want to go behind
the scenes or have a chat with us we've
just started playing Monster Hunter
world together and I have no idea what's
going I really utilize our skills here
yeah I love this video
I think Shelby is her name's Shelby yeah
I think you are wonderful
just as the format alone I think is
great I love the usage of taking clips
from movies or some type of YouTube
video whatever and doing the whole me
boyfriend thing yeah it's like this
visual gag bit - and answer you're
talking about at least rating what the
experience is like the whole editing I
think is great I love the energy of this
video and I also really love your timing
though your delivery is so damn funny
like you're [ __ ] hysterical I don't
know if you're ever gonna watch this
video but I'm talking to you as if you
are I'll never make a video as good as
this ever well I love the hook to just
have so magnetized view
wind up watching other people play video
games I would like to review from that
perspective I think is actually kind of
a brilliant idea the amount of humor and
the amount of observation you can bring
when you're not in the driver's seat is
pretty special yeah cuz this made me
want to play but it also made me just
want to be around somebody playing I
mean it's such a good point like because
so many games I was talking to my
girlfriend about this we bought two
controllers for our ps4 it's hard to
find like story based adventure games
that are two-player compatible that
actually go through a storyline in some
capacity where you're both actually
important yeah you know where it's you
know a versing game or some online co-op
game which are fun but you know we
wanted to like do an adventure together
how many times you want to solve mystery
yeah I'm playing spider-man right now
she's playing God of War so I'm I'll be
in the backseat while she's doing god of
war and showed me in the backseat I'm
doing spider-man and often times we lose
interest cuz we're not playing so I
think the concept of like hey if you if
there's a game that you personally can't
actually get your hands on but you're
kind of in a position to watch a log
with
significant other a roommate or whatever
these are the kind of games that you
could still really enjoy if you're
sitting on the sidelines that concept is
cool of course guys as auto-5 falls in
that queue that's great they thought oh
man yeah I mean I feel like this series
could improve a lot of relationships you
know especially for like game or cards
and stuff like that you know you
understand your significant others in
such a gamer but you don't want them to
be bored out of their mind you know you
could consult these videos and the thing
that I I had to laugh at at the very end
of this is like people still get
outraged about Grand Theft Auto like do
people still protest this game yeah
after so was like it's never changed its
tune I mean you can't ask them to stop
fighting though I guess not it's like
one could say the same thing about
Donald Trump we get used to the stuff
that he does it's crazy does that mean
we should stop being like hey that's
wrong mr. president well if we allege
exact same thing if we elect him four
more times than you yes Donald Trump is
grandpa which you know there's got to be
some kind of Trump character in these
game you know there is fun fact John
taught me what seeman was when I was
playing Grand Theft Auto 3 during the
summertime and he told me what it was
when I was on the phone with him because
I had a question about a specific
situation that is odd my honor
why why did I come home come with that
information did was just like great
quick biology lesson but I was playing
seven I have a very slim every being on
my literary calculation I know you got
to break some goons kneecaps right now
but your body is gonna start producing
some stuff gonna be great it's your
story this is a great channel I'm
definitely gonna be watching every once
in awhile you patrons link us to a
channel we've never seen or say we've
never seen and then suddenly I'm binge
watching so much them on my own time so
create them thank you
if you haven't done so yet subscribe to
girl from reviews I honestly thought
this would be from bitola though this
would be something where it's like were
primarily female demographic or
something you know but I think there's
very universal silo yeah I feel like
yeah if you're if
like games and you like humor you could
get something out of this but if you're
actually in this position you could also
act like that would be a negative - I
have a yeah obsession with Britney's
women's don't deserve reviews of video
games unless they're gonna play them
remember female demographic like Britney
Spears is mainly for female demo but I'm
a huge Britney Spears man and you're
breaking the mold man it's being on
individual subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell Pete Don
thank you so much again amigo you have
been venturing out on writing very
recently I know we talked about it in
our last video I think put the pursuit
of making a career out of being a writer
is a guarantee that no struggles are
gonna happen along the way it's easy
sailing in fact you don't live in LA if
you want to know the cliche about moving
to LA you move here you make it two
months top so I think you should come
out to LA pursue a career say to the
family and move over here yeah this is a
lucrative career you'll make a lot of
money I mean like ten bucks per words is
usually how you want to think about it
so like you're missing out man you're
missing out on it we're just lazy and
that's why we haven't made it yeah we
could be celebrity Hollywood writers if
we want if we wanted to but when you're
you grow up used to it you have a lack
of ambition just everyone around us
everyone's a famous writer try it out
Pete